قنبله
موقتات تهدد وموقوتات تهدد ايران ونصف
سكانها مع وصول القشره الارضيه فيها الى
حاله وصفت بالحرجه للغايه احدث التقييمات
والخرائط اشارت الى ان المساحه التقليديه
لمناطق الهبوط الارضي في ايران تصل الى
اكثر من 18 مليون هكتار اي ما يعادل 11%
من اجمالي مساحه ايران بمعنى ان اكثر من
39 مليون شخص معرضون للخطر اي ما يعادل 39
او 49% من سكان البلاد القشره الارضيه
مشاهدينا التي تمر باسوء حالاتها قد تعرض
380 مدينه وتسعه الاف ومئتي قريه لخطر
هبوط الارض بسكانها وفق طبعا خبراء اما
اكثر المحافظات عرضه لهذا الخطر فهي
العاصمه الايرانيه طهران وخرسان واصفهان
فيما محافظه خرسان المرتبه الاولى من حيث
المساحه للمناطق المعرضه لخطر الهبوط علما
بان مناطق سهل مشهد شمالي شرقي ايران سجلت
بالفعل حالات هبوط ارضيه واسعه تراوحت بين
ثلاثه سنتيمترات و17 سم وفي حين ان الهبوط
الذي يتم التحكم فيه في دول مثل اليابان
والولايات المتحده والصين يصل الى سنتيمتر
واحد في السنه يؤكد خطوره الوضع في ايران
وصول الهبوط الارضي الى هذه المرحله من
التازم سببه طبعا الجفاف الدائم
والاستخدام المفرط للمياه الجوفيه
والسياسات الخاطئه واثاره دائمه كموت
طبقات المياه الجوفيه وتدمير الزراعه
وتحويل السهول لسحاره وخلق شقوق عميقه ما
يهدد احيانا استمرار الحياه في منطقه
جغرافيه محدده
[موسيقى]